تشرح الكيمياء [موسيقى]
حرفيًا كل
ما يحدث حول اليهود ، حيث
تستهلك الألواح الجافة الطاقة الحرارية
من الماء ،
وللأسف ، يتم الحكم علي فورًا بناءً
على مظهري ، وهو أمر
محبط للغاية بالنسبة لي ، لذا سأقوم بشراء
المياه الساخنة عند مجيئي
هنا وسأرميها مباشرة في
دلو الخاص بي ، حسنًا ، هذا يعني أنني يجب أن أعمل
بجدية أكبر ولكن في النهاية الأمر
يستحق كل هذا العناء بشكل لا يصدق ، واسمي
د.  أنا كيت بي بيرجدورف وأنا محاضر
في جامعة تكساس في أوستن
[موسيقى]
أحاول كسر وصمة العار التي
تبدو عليها العالمة النمطية ، لذا فإن
الشيء الذي أشعر به هو أنني لا أرتدي ربطة عنق
ولا أرتدي الحمالات.  لا
أمتلك كارديجانًا مزيفًا ، فأنا مجرد
فتاة عادية تحب اللعب بالنار وأحب
أيضًا أحذية المصمم ولا
بأس بذلك
لأن الألجينات تضرب
كلوريد الكالسيوم ، ويفضل الألجينات أن تكون
مع اثنين زائد شحن الكالسيوم
بدلاً من شحنة الصوديوم الإضافية ، وما
يحدث هو أننا نشكل ديدانًا صمغية.
من خلال العلم ، أستخدم أي
شيء يجعل
الطلاب الأربعمائة وثلاثة وثمانين طالبًا يجلسون بشكل مستقيم
ويستمعون فعليًا إلى الكلمات التي
تخرج من فمك بمجرد أن
أنفجر شيئًا في وجوههم ، فأنا
لفت انتباههم لمدة 60 ثانية فقط
يمكنني القيام بكل ما في وسعي لدفع هذه
المعرفة إلى أدمغتهم ، حسنًا ،
ما سنفعله اليوم هو إجراء
بعض الكيمياء سنقوم بثلاث
تجارب عملية مختلفة أجد
أن الكيمياء
موضوع صعب للغاية  لقد سئمت من
القوالب النمطية للعالمات
ويمكننا القيام بأشياء أخرى غير علم الأحياء ، في كلتا الحالتين ،
يمكننا القيام بهندسة فيزياء الكيمياء
وحقيقة أنني تمكنت من
إتقانها ولكن بعد ذلك استخدم العلم
لبدء المحادثة ولكن بعد ذلك
أقف جسديًا  هناك وتحطيم تلك الصورة ،
إنها أكثر شيء مجزي يمكن أن أفعله على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]